kids breakfast
kids
oh
phil would you get them yeah just suck
kids
kids get down here why are you guys
yelling at us when we're way upstairs
just text me all right that's not gonna
happen and wow you're not wearing that
outfit what's wrong with it honey do you
have anything to say to your daughter
about her skirt
sorry
oh yeah that looks really cute
sweetheart thanks no it's way too short
people know you're a girl you don't need
to prove it to them luke got his head
stuck in the banister again i got it
where's the baby oil it's our bedside
tip
i don't know find it
come on i was
out of control growing up there you know
i said it i i
i just don't want my kids to make the
same bad mistakes i made
if haley never wakes up on a beach in
florida half-naked
i've done my job
our job
right
i've done our job
[Music]
where is the penalty gloria they're all
in six let's take it down a notch
we're very different
jay's from the city he has a big
business
i come from a small village very poor
but very very beautiful it's the number
one village in north colombia for all
day
what's the word murders
yes the murders
mommy is stopping stopping into it
[Music]
damn it manny
come on coach you gotta take that kid
out you wanna take him out
how about i take you out honey honey why
don't you worry about your son he spent
the first half with his hand in his
pants
i've wanted to tell her after the last
six weeks
i'm josh ryan's there hi i'm gloria
pritchett manny's mother
oh this must be your dad her dad yeah no
no that's funny actually no i'm her
husband don't be fooled by the uh
give me a second here
who is a good girl who's that
who's that oh she's adorable oh thank
you hi precious hello
hi hi
we just we just adopted her from vietnam
and we're bringing her home for the
first time huh oh she's an angel you and
your wife must be thrilled sorry sorry
sorry daddy needed snacks hi
so
what are we talking about
uh we have been together for
five five years now
and uh we just we decided we really want
to have a baby so we had initially asked
one of our lesbian friends to be a
surrogate then we figured
they're already mean enough can you
imagine one of them pregnant
no thank you nick
you saw that right
everybody fawning over lily and then you
walk on and suddenly it's all ooh
skymall i gotta buy a motorized tie rack
all right you know i'm gonna give the
speech you are not giving the speech
you're gonna be stuck with these people
for the next five right you're right
okay i'm sorry
look at that baby with those cream puffs
okay excuse me excuse me but this baby
would have grown up in a crowded
orphanage if it wasn't for us cream
puffs and you know what no to all of you
who judge hear this
love knows no race creed or gender and
shame on you you small-minded ignorant
few what
she's got
oh
we would like to pay for everyone's
headsets
buddy why do you keep getting stuck like
this i thought i could get out this time
i'm just gonna say it
he needs to be checked by a specialist
ah
ow there be free excalibur
i'm having a friend over today who uh
you don't know him
him him
ooh
a boy you're gonna kiss him shut up easy
easy
alex why don't you take it outside okay
and do what fight in the sun it'll be a
nice change alien
i'm kidding who's the boy
his name is dylan you know i might as
well just tell him not to come because
you guys are just going to embarrass me
hang on a second you're 15 and it's the
first time you've had a boy over i mean
i'm bound to be a little surprised but i
can embarrass you i better go charge the
camcorder
i'm kidding come on who are you talking
to
i'm the cool dad that's that's my thing
[Music]
you